and we already see the opening yeah the
opening and it's the ready opening from
Magnus Carlson very flexible stuff
bringing the White Knight out on move
one this is actually something I've
played against manager of plenty of
times before just because I want to kind
of kill the fun if you go direct if you
open with one E4 or one D4 the most kind
of traditional most popular moves in
chess he has some really aggressive
weapons there so uh by doing what Magnus
has done just pushing a pawn now Magnus
is guaranteed a very solid setup White's
Bishop is going to feel keto White's
King has a nice home now on the king
side there won't be that many exchanges
the position won't open up yet
and manager of playing a bit of CopyCat
pushing a pawn as well this is known to
be very very solid for black yeah I have
to say this type of formation is also
very popular with Shaq I mean I see it a
lot in his games I mean he tends to
favor it by pushing the d-pawn two
squares forward and both players will be
in the element especially in the opening
I've actually seen them have this
position 4 in the past and I think that
time Magnus pushed his a pawn forward
two squares just creating a pawn
sacrifice it looks a bit like a Queen's
Gambit now uh White and it looks very
much like a queen's camp but now white
is giving up this Pawn that's just been
captured and
traditionally this has a very dodgy
reputation actually for white but modern
computers have shown that white does
have sufficient compensation for the
pawn that's been sacrificed yeah and
look at this Magnus stirring up into the
air my major are playing instantly
they've both studied this before I think
they've both prepared this exact
variation
definitely and I know that Shaq is very
familiar with this Pawn structure he
does like to grab the pawn so he's not
he's not averse to being a pawn up but
having an uncomfortable position and
Magnus we've seen this type of thing
from him many occasions and there he
goes Knight gets developed yeah and the
reason we say that Black's position is a
bit uncomfortable is because if you look
at the center of the board white has
those beautiful pawns on e4 D4
either of them could step forward at any
moment you could make an argument for
stepping forward with one of them now
one Pawn could hit a knight if you push
white teeth on the other Pawn uh deep
Pawn stepping forward would explode the
position open look at why it's rook in
the center as well staring down at the
black queen indirectly yeah it's a
tension filled position and uh both
sides have reason to be happy Magnus
doesn't care about being a pawn down
this is modern Magnus Magnus 2.0 since
2019 he loves these types of ideas but
uh okay he does step forward immediately
he does and up until this point so they
were actually following a game that Shaq
played with the white pieces against
Richard a rapport in the aim chess rapid
so we'll be fresh in his memory and
wasn't that an epic game oh not the from
the preliminaries yeah was it back it
was it was the game for Knockouts okay
yeah and uh we have just I mean it was
so quick we almost missed it there it
was lightning fast but we've just seen a
few moves and mamajarov has sacrificed a
knight for three pawns and this is
really dramatic because he has great
compensation for the night of black
spawns look at all of them there's eight
pawns still on the board white only has
five left so if we do a bit of counting
white has a knight black has three pawns
technically it's balanced but who does
it favor here I'm loving the Aesthetics
of Black's Pawn structure to be honest
especially on this left side of the
board they're so far Advanced they look
fantastic but White's Knights are
getting ready to jump around they're a
bit tricky to deal with and both players
have gained time from when they started
the game it's already moved 14 in a very
extremely rare uh opening and this is I
mean this isn't surprise for me this is
not Magnus playing it safe I said play
boring try and just slowly grind down
Shaq that's your best bet but nope he's
again trying to fight fire with fire and
and this one is uh is started really
really exciting uh excitingly so is it
Mom diaro sacrificing a night for three
pawns or Magnus sacrificing three points
for a night
it's a good question Kyle it's like uh
is the sky blue
what came first the chicken or the egg
yeah but uh yeah I mean normally we say
you've sacrificed if you've given up a
piece rather than pawns even though
technically it's a level material right
now and the reason I say sacrifice as
well white Knights do look pretty good
one of them is in the black half already
on that left side it can jump back if it
needs to the other night might jump
forward now uh but okay first Magnus
secures he anchors that Knight on B5 to
an outpost with this Pawn push you said
that yesterday that's a very Magnus move
he loves pushing that April he loves
pushing yeah and again this is Magnus
ever since 2019 when Alpha zero really
revolutionized top level chess by
pushing Harry the H Pawn up the board
and also pushing the a pawn up the board
it's just all about space it's about
control actually in a way by pushing
over once you activate the Rooks behind
them and yeah Magnus not just has he
taken on that as one of his main
characteristics in chess but he's also
he's embraced these kind of positions
where there's great imbalances before
2019 Magnus was reluctant often to enter
these types of murky Waters and uh okay
my major develops his Bishop also a very
sensible move this is the type of game
we'll see the evaluation bus swing quite
a lot because free human it's far from
rational it's uh hard to negotiate yeah
definitely how to negotiate I mean
there's so much danger for both sides if
Magnus doesn't utilize his extra piece
in a good way then Black's pawns or
simply again overrun the position
meanwhile the reverse is true you know
if Shaq doesn't mobilize his Pawns in a
good way if they get stopped by the
piece well then white has an extra piece
to attack the black position with so
drama filled position I I think a boring
draw is the least likely a result of all
we're going to see it win or lose a lot
I think we can forget the word boring
for this uh this matchup the whole day I
think we're going to forget that one
word and uh yeah this is just chaotic
and they're so principled these two
players we see other players in the
field such as Wesley so and ichigiri
they adapt their game according to the
opponent but these two they're just so
principled no matter who they play Shaq
is going to attack and Magnus is going
to try and uh kind of surprise his
opponent take them into positions that
his understanding is deeper
yeah I mean here I'm loving those white
Knights to be honest often we call these
Superfluous Knights meaning that one
night is useless they're both fighting
for the same square but uh especially
when they protect each other like this
but those two white Knights they're both
on great squares right now and yeah I
mean it's I think we can also forget
about all long-term factors because it's
just purely move by move just uh who can
create threats who can create those Pawn
pushes if you're mama giraffe who can uh
who can
when the opponent at least expects it
unleash some uh some tactics yeah we're
in for a sparkling day of Chess and uh
whilst Shaq is thinking well we do have
a brain teaser quiz of a day because we
are asking today
for everyone to solve this puzzle it's
why to play and it's Checkmate in two
moves now uh everyone you make this is a
difficult one so you should gather your
friends your family together and have a
go and let us know was it difficult how
did you solve it did you tweet cheats I
was gonna say did you tweet did you
cheat yeah are you giving up let us know
and you can do that by tweeting us using
the hashtag chess Champs you can also
send us pictures of yourself solving the
puzzle yeah together I mean you're
probably gonna need to gather your
friends and family for this this is a
puzzle that our producer brought in
yesterday and it had the whole crew here
in the Oslo Studio working we gave it to
David and David said wow this is the
most difficult mate into I've ever seen
and then he solved it four seconds later
but still it's very difficult it's
extremely difficult and you guys
mentioned Gathering friends I think this
is where you need to really spitball
ideas I'll give you one hint the obvious
moves on not necessarily the best ones
and there's only one solution in order
to force Checkmate on your second move
as white so yeah set it up on a board
send those pictures in of you trying to
solve it I'm expecting lots of heads in
hands because it's really complicated
and final hint process of elimination
you might have to try nearly every legal
move on the board to get there but uh
yeah think outside the box and you will
eventually find that answer yeah I I
like these type of puzzles because often
it's a good idea as well to work
backwards to find the checkmates to
think about the possible checkmates and
then kind of work backwards and think
about how you're going to get there and
it's a study because you never really
see a configuration like that so also
like David says think outside the box
jump out of it it's super fun as well to
sit down either by yourself or with
friends and family and just really try
hard I know you were trying your hand at
solving it yeah I tried I couldn't do it
super difficult ah it's kind of half
chess half logic and uh
I know lots of programmers or lots of
people who work in different spheres
where you have to problem solve on a
day-to-day basis I think you can use
some of the skills here and uh yeah yeah
I think it's almost as if Magnus is
trying to solve this puzzle he looks so
confused yeah it's uh yeah it's one of
those uh one of those days today we're
expecting lots of brilliant chess on the
board and that is a brilliant puzzle so
I'm hoping some of you do try your hand
would Magna solve it immediately if we
just showed him this puzzle why would he
need time to think he would need a bit
of time I remember I think it was
earlier this year I gave a puzzle we
took some of the players when they were
in Oslo down to the good night and I
gave mama jarov I gave Anish giri Eric
Hanson and Yoder van Forrest maybe one
of the other kind of toughest mate in
two puzzles that I've ever seen and it
took me maybe five ten minutes to solve
it that one and I showed it to them
Anish giri within 30 seconds he was up
there showing off the answer but the
others were still struggling to
understand even after he'd shown the
answer so
um yeah I mean these guys are good
they're Geniuses but even they need a
bit of time sometimes yeah
and after a bit of time four minutes we
do see move from my mom jar of yeah and
those two white Knights were too
beautiful to allow to live so namjorov
has captured one of them traded it off
the board but he's also allowed a kind
of Invader and an intruder in the black
Camp look at that white people now are
you surprised Ivanka that white took
back with the pawn this white Pawn now
on B5 is either very strong or it's very
weak I'm not especially surprised that
he took back with the pawn because uh
there is that danger if the Knight had
hopped to the B5 Square it could be
offside because the action is happening
in the center it's all about restraining
that poor pawn pawn mass and uh I think
it's a good idea for from white to open
up some lines for The Rook yeah the
benefit is actually keeping this Rook on
A1 you haven't moved it but it's
suddenly become active and that's why we
always nowadays become accustomed to
these players kind of pushing their
pawns just like Magnus did in this
position and you don't always have to
swing your Rook across the board in
order to get it active like this often
you can just activate it without even
moving it and that's what Magnus has
done in the current position if we go
back to it yeah I would have been very
tempted I think just to take with a
knight just plant it on this Outpost
that we talked about it can nearly never
be removed from this square but Magnus
is more keen he feels it's more a
priority to activate his rook and also
now for the first time maybe we can talk
about long-term factors this is the only
real past Pawn in the game there is one
on D5 for black but it is well blockaded
so actually long term if material starts
to disappear this could be a real trump
card uh trump card up magnus's sleeve
meanwhile namkarov removes this Rook but
big threat on the board we talked about
the pawns versus the piece it's
essentially these pawns against one of
White's minor pieces and they're getting
ready to mobilize by shifting his Rook
across he's threatening to start pushing
if you can start pushing Pawns
momentum will turn in Black's favor if
animation bar doesn't like it though it
did go up for Magnus after that move
yeah and often if we do see the
evaluation bar swing sides switch sides
here switch allegiances it will be
because of tactics and direct tricks I
don't see anything right now for Magnus
you kind of want to stop this Pawn
moving forward but uh I don't think you
should kind of
week in your own position by pushing
your own pawns here this would stop
black pushing but now you weaken
yourself your King's diagonal there
might be some weaknesses here long term
knowing my luck this is what Magnus will
play now but uh I think first of all you
want to look at threats it's the same in
Puzzles like we said with that mate in
two puzzle for example you want to look
at threats first of all this is maybe um
a threatening move hitting the black
queen you could maybe consider bringing
this bishop out to a variety of squares
you have to be careful if you put it on
a square like this one yes you stop the
pawn moving or do you because suddenly
after you capture it you're in an
eternal pin so this is all of these
ideas the players are looking at right
now and it's it's complicated that the
price of one move is extremely high
that's the type of Chess manager of
place if the opponent makes one slip
often things turn against them and okay
Magnus I'm surprised he played quite
quickly there after just a minute or two
of thought he pushed his Pawn forward
there were so many options the idea is
to force black to commit if black takes
this Pawn then lines are opening up and
that will favor white pieces rather than
the bronze although even now it does
look a bit scary that these pawns are
running and the alternative for black is
to move forward and this would create a
protected past one two squares away from
promotion long term it's great but short
term is not really going anywhere the
square in front of it is well blockaded
by White's Queen and by White Knight
so do you block it do you open it
maybe manager a style more to open it
what do you think Ivanka yeah it's a
difficult choice for mamajaro for my
vibe is actually to capture the pawn
because I'm slightly afraid that if the
porn does March forward which is the
most aesthetically pleasing move the
pawn won't get any further and suddenly
all of Black's horns on the left are
three pawns they cannot move and I'm
afraid that the apron will be a Target
yeah
now this is actually quite a serious
Target long term Black's rook in the
corner might have to remain passive
defending it uh so yeah blocking it up
normally that's what you want to do and
that's why it's such a difficult
decision from Amador that's why he's
spending a minute or so here because
normally you want to
push gain space create that thorn and
white side long term but here I think it
was a wise decision for him to capture
at least now if you compare he does have
two protected connected passports
and I I just took a look at the computer
assessment this was the only way to
survive in the position I'm already my
job was spreading that tightrope and uh
Pawn takes Pawn definitely the best
solution and it's primarily because the
black pawns maintain their flexibility
yeah now you can make an argument for
pushing this guy forward immediately
trying to run down the board or I guess
you could try to start rounding up
White's Pawn not sure how you go for it
immediately It is Well defended for now
um also I'm making it maybe a mistaken
assumption here that white is actually
after Pawn to explore film to recapture
Magnus has paused is he looking for
something other than this it looks
almost suicidal at this moment to leave
these pawns alive do you think he's uh
going to jump forward with a knight and
try to attack the base of the pawn chain
the A5 Pawn Yeah so you hit gain time
against the queen you hit that and uh if
you can win the A5 Pawn
so that's a very good start I think the
problem for black here is where's the
queen going to go there's no safe
squares along this diagonal actually
because if you plant the queen on this
Square you get hit by White's bishop and
uh likewise if you plant plant the queen
on this Square you will get hit by the
white Bishop as well you lose time
oh if Magnus plays that move he's got I
mean he's in a brief Brave mood today
so this is the current position uh sorry
this one and I'm expecting him just to
keep things simple but no wow Magnus
just blocking the Pawns
he I mean Rooks are not good blockadas
so that's got to be said uh but this is
really creative his idea is that this
Pawn is not running away uh he's going
to take it at leisure at will and then
this Pawn behind the A5 Pawn is fixed in
its place
I mean how do you come up with a move
like that that would not be on my radar
at all this is what separates the top 10
players in the world uh from the rest of
us is just so creative
and it looks pretty decent the
evaluation bar still likes white and
suddenly when Magnus plays it it all
makes sense as well you're like of
course
you absolutely do not need to capture
the pawn instead restrain the pawns that
is after all what good old nimsovich and
old classical author wrote you know you
should restrain those past pawns stop
them from advancing yeah makes perfect
sense but it's so interesting how Magnus
is able just to recall those rules at
will and just not forget about things in
the heat of the calculation and battle
Yeah that's what they say they say block
surround Target and capture and that's
going to happen to the black pawns most
likely yeah and it definitely has mom
and yarrow thinking I hope you guys at
home are thinking about our very cool
chess puzzle I sent it to Tanya as well
for her to uh test it on the people in
San Francisco are you guys solving the
puzzle Tanya
guy at the moment we got that email we
knew we had to solve that puzzle the
chess player in me has taken over we've
got a bunch of chess players here with
us actually uh including one of the top
players from the United States we've got
Carissa yep here with us we've got uh
Bryce who is 2500 Robbie as well Bharat
and I've got the puzzle set up it's a
white to play made into this is a puzzle
for the viewers today we've got a little
competition going on to see who gets it
right so let's take a look
all right guys so white to play mate
into your timer Starts Now
I'm trying it as well
Bharat has an answer already but are you
sure
all right let's see what is it
that's a check
and then that is a wrong one so let's
just put it back one more shot
guys this one's really tough
while we've got a bunch of really strong
players trying this out all the best to
our viewers with this puzzle we'll be
back with the answer
it's really tough it is a tough one and
I I can see some people have tried their
luck on Twitter sending us what they
think is the answer and I can just tell
everyone you got it wrong oh no one has
got it right so far so carry on working
at it yeah and take a picture of the
screen right now this is the puzzle
white to play made into take a picture
so you can show it to your friends and
family and work on it throughout Today's
Show
cool they haven't been able to solve it
in San Francisco can you guys at home
solve it
and um
he did make a move okay we have some
moves on the board yeah both sides have
made a move uh Black's Knight has
re-routed itself and Magnus has taken
the opportunity after Black's night
moved to go and capture the first black
pawn we advocated for this earlier White
tonight's stepping back and uh that has
happened so now the material balance yet
again is a knight or a piece for three
pawns so level material but blacks pawns
are all blocks it's hard to move any of
them right now
I mean those two on the queen side
blocked Black's two Central Pawns it's
not safe to move them
it looks like Magnus is asserted control
uh-huh yeah the evaluation bar still
says it's in the balance but it does
feel like the stakes are higher for Mama
jarov oh and I have to say once again
according to the computer
there's only one move that will maintain
the balance everything else will give
white a huge Advantage probably almost
winning as well and that is black has to
mobilize the Knight he has to put it
towards the center and actually deposit
on the C4 Square okay so uh that's not
100 obvious it makes a lot of sense
again once you've said it first of all
you would look at pushing pawns you
would look at
maybe developing The Black Queen let's
show this one move look at the clock
times as well down to four and a half
minutes this is how difficult it is for
manager if he's walking a tightrope
already the key move as Ivanka mentions
is this one bringing the Knight into the
center
um it's easy to look the other direction
for example you could bring the Knight
to attack the white Rook this doesn't
work because white thread could now take
a pawn uh Black's Queen no longer
defends this Pawn so this uh you can
kind of throw this one out quite quickly
but manager of will he find a key idea
the whole concept
as if Uncle mentions is when this Knight
is attacked or at some point it will
plant itself on a nice Outpost it
doesn't look like the maybe the most
secure Outpost but it's strong enough
for now and there will be threats for
example of jumping in forking the two
white Rooks
um so this is the key if he doesn't find
this night jump
it's going to be all about Magnus and
his extra pieces the black pawns will be
less relevant
three minutes now can he find it he's
down eight minutes on the clock yeah
this I was just going to say the big
problem for Mama Jarvis if he does not
find this move then the white forces are
just going to swing themselves over to
the A-line and the pawn on A5 is
indefensible
so there's only one move the timing is
now he has to play it yeah he has to
play it and actually the logic is here
essentially when white slides over to
attack this Pawn your knight is just in
time to come and defend it and uh yeah
you'd hold everything together and the
game goes on the balance is maintained
but uh this is what I mean about kind of
taking your opponent into that deep dark
Forest often they only have that one
move every time otherwise the evaluation
swings if they find it they have a good
position as mamajarov would here but
it's so difficult when every turn you're
being forced to be so accurate you can't
just rely on an instinct in a position
like this one you have to calculate you
have to be precise
and uh yeah I mean I'm not sure I would
find it I've got to be honest but uh
mama jarov I have faith in him it's just
costing him so much time spent four
minutes on this one move and we're only
on move 20.
it could be decisive later in the game
it looks like starting with the white
pieces it's just a huge huge benefit in
this uh matchup between these two do you
think you will fly and find it you said
you have belief I'm thinking is he's
taken a long time I'm not sure he's
gonna get there they do say long think
wrong think right so the longer he takes
the less likely he is to find it but
okay Knight to E5 that is the move we're
looking for from amateur of anything
else
white is ticking under two minutes after
20 moves Magnus still has more than 11
minutes on the clock
even if he finds this move this is going
to be dramatic this won't be the last
time in the game that he's got a narrow
path to find uh manager there will be
future moments critical even more
critical than this perhaps where he has
to find only moves and how can you do
that with one minute against 11. and
also against this happy chappie
I mean he looks like he's in full
control he's perfectly satisfied with
his pieces and he doesn't find it he did
some calculation here and he okay we see
a bunch of quick moves a bunch of
exchanges so he's relying upon this
variation mamajarov he calculated it but
it doesn't work uh for black so right
now both Queens are attacked White's
Knight could have taken the black queen
but White Queen would have fallen to the
Black Knight so uh both Queens had to
run out of the attacks and the reason
this has not been a good transition for
managerov is simply he's lost a pawn and
you're running out of Pawns so now white
has an extra piece an extra Bishop for
only two pawns that is quite a
significant advantage and there is a
couple of threats on the board Black
Knight is attacking White's Rook Black's
Queen is attacking a pawn but Magnus can
just safely move his work out the way I
feel and uh yeah there are other
importance ripe for picking white
tonight is going to retreat and take the
Blackboard on B4 at some point
everything's just starting to collapse
wow
totally is and this looks like he's
digging this position and it looks like
it's a great start to the day for
actually all the players in San
Francisco the bar is way over to Wesley
Seoul side in game one against Arjun
aragaisy Wesley who has lost both
matches so far looks like he's gonna get
a great start against Arjun on day three
and in the game between Duda sitting in
Poland against
um giri sitting in San Francisco I think
the bar is slightly over to anishikiri's
side this is a battle between two
players who have won both of the first
matches Geary in tie breaks and then
pragnananda who had a horrible day
yesterday he won the first two games
against giri
but then lost the match in Blitz tie
breaks but here on day three first game
against Liam the bar is way over to his
side really looks like the atmosphere is
good in San Francisco today yeah it
feels like the players they're getting
in their groove they're starting to
motor now after yeah a bit of a slow
start especially from Wesley and Prague
but I'm looking over those positions
especially for Prague it's such I mean
such incredible bounce back ability as
we say in sport just to turn it around
after yesterday which was really
heartbreaking we've got to say losing
what was it three games in a row
yesterday Prague when he was on the
brink of victory
already he's dominant in that first game
against Liam lay
Magnus meanwhile yeah he's just nodding
he's got boss mode on right now
swigging water
it looks very good now under one minute
as well for my major
10 and a half minutes down on the clock
and he's down on the board as well
material
it looks one-sided traffic now and it
just turned on that one move that one
moment that night jump which direction
to go with the Knight centralize the
night or go off to the side
and I think that's one Pitfall that I've
fallen for thousands of times in my life
a lot of players do we try to calculate
in a position where we should just be
improving our pieces like best move
which just improve his night he
calculated but three four moves down the
line he's starting to shake his head
he's just pulling down he's gonna be
more he's under 30 seconds and this is
the problem with chaotic positions you
know you have to either calculate or as
Davis says just uh take those simple
decisions to improve your pieces and the
problem here for shark is just simply a
piece down
and after Knight takes born well can you
no no no no no no no no I fell for that
trap there
because uh Shaq is relying on the bishop
swooping into the C3 Square attacking
the rook and the Knight yeah it gets
really complicated actually here uh
Magnus is doing some calculation he can
take two different pawns but uh one you
have to do a lot of calculation the
other one I think you can play quite
safely and uh like you said Ivanka the
first natural one is to take this pawn
it looks very dangerous but you have to
do some calculation after the bishop
swoops in to attack the rook and attack
the Knight and here there are tricks I'm
trying to work it out I'm not sure if
the evaluation but if White's night okay
he's taking the other bomb but White
Knight could for example have taken here
there's a pin along this line and we do
some calculation this is capture this is
a check and at the end if Black's King
takes his Knight there might have been a
fork so maybe this was possible but uh
Magnus decided okay this was too long A
variation five or six moves deep why not
keep things simple and take another Pawn
instead Bishop takes pawn and again this
utilizes a pin on the e-file blacks Pawn
cannot go and take this bishop because
of Rook takes Rook whoops Rook takes a
rook with a check
so um yeah Magnus taking a pawn back
utilizing this pin The Rook was attacked
now you just maintain the tension on the
e-file and Max King moves so right now
white has an extra Bishop for just two
pawns the two pawns are at least for now
blockaded
and uh okay Magnus takes a step back and
he's going to take another step back
with his Bishop just to make sure that
this Pawn never ever advances
should still be good for like there's
still some work to be done definitely
some work to be done I mean it's not
easy at all but and he retreated his
Bishop to a different Square I didn't
expect that one I thought he would keep
an eye on the passport and instead
deciding that the Knight is the best
locator for that piece
uh the big problem for Magnus though is
that if black were just simply just to
hold tight it's not necessarily that
clear of how white is going to round up
the Renegade Pawn on B4 yeah that's true
you can blockade this Pawn uh which
Magnus will most likely do right now or
on the next turn and but once you
blockade it yeah it still takes a lot of
work maybe 10 15 moves to even try and
threaten the spawn okay Magnus uh this
is a very Magnus type of move just
improving his King instead the pawns are
starting to roll for Mama jar of uh he
wants to start advancing this Pawn as
well I'm expecting Magnus at some point
as well to take a timeout maybe just to
block the advance
of black Central Pawn so this Pawn might
be blocked if white pushes points F3 and
this point will be blocked as well it is
winning we know it's winning these two
players know it's winning but it does
take time
and we have seen Magnus occasionally
slip up
uh throughout the tour this season it's
normally when he relaxes a bit too early
yeah but here I think he will be on
point I I think this is the type of
position where you have to keep your
vigilance because one slip up and
suddenly the black pieces will become
active and the past B Pawn is very very
dangerous
so
definitely work to be done I'm
predicting that like you say restrain
the pawn then the night rest treats
backwards some pieces get improved
yeah lock this pawn and uh I mean the
clock time is and the other main
significant factor right now it's going
to be so hard for my major with one
minute left to find any defensive
resources or to even seize an
opportunity even if Magnus gives him one
how do you calculate your way out of
trouble with only one minute left
looking very good for white and we might
say that a lot today looking good for
white especially between these two these
two players and stylistically as well
Mama jar of he can get the type of
positions he wants when he has the white
pieces he can play on the front foot
from move one in this game he never
really got there he played that really
really dramatic controversial peace
sacrifice for three pawns I'll still
call it sacrifice but it hasn't really
paid off
Queens are on the board it might be a
different situation but right now
without Queens we can see my Majora's
pain so frustrated yeah he the problem
also okay not only is he material down
he will have to calculate what is going
to happen after every peace trade you
know is it possible for white to trade
off Bishops is it possible to trade off
Rooks is it going to be good for him
chances are he cannot trade a single
piece and uh there you see he is
suffering and Magnus just improves his
Rook he's getting ready to trade off the
dark Square Bishops
yeah and he has to remember Mom Madero
he's probably going to lose with the
black pieces in all the games today but
he's probably also going to win it with
the white pieces no yeah there's no
reason to lose hope but he's still got
two whites today uh in the rapid section
uh maybe we'll have a few more whites as
well wait one second if everyone wins
with the whites
okay yeah like this as the leader in the
tour standings can choose colors in the
Armageddon you would choose white but
that that means if everyone is going to
win with the white pieces then Shaq has
to win in the next round excited yeah
definitely Black's King coming towards
the center but this isn't really going
to help there's too many pieces left on
the board for the Kings to play a major
role right now and white as expected
does just drop back on blockade Shack
he's trying to push pawns fair play to
him there is a saying that if you're
down on pawns you should change exchange
pieces if you're down in pieces which
Shack is here you should try and
exchange pawns so even if Black's pawns
on this side sorry even if they advance
and trade off that could oh uh saving
chances it's over wow Shaq just resigns
okay it was losing but that feels
premature and early resignation from
Shaq with whites Rook about to get
active